but I have something funny that I heard  that you did that I can't believe you  did and I didn't even do if I lost a  dare you put your phone number on the  Internet  yeah yeah yeah people can hit me up you  know I'm saying 9 175 400 5512 yeah yeah  I've been texting with people I don't  know I don't answer like all the time  all the time but I definitely answer  people and connect with people and try  to send encouraging messages whether  video or text and just just trying to  talk people you know uplifted and  elevated yeah it's really cool it's a  really cool way to like just stay in  touch with people and just give people  love I just wanted to connect with the  people and uh it was a great opportunity  to be able to do it and in a cool way  and it really is true it really is my  number and it works so it's cool that's  really cool of you subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel please don't make me keep going